ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show 24 hours late we wanted to
do it from the studio for you
uh doesn't happen often we hope it
doesn't happen again
here with ben avery i want to comment on
something we got a lot to talk about
today but i want to comment on something
because i don't ever like when somebody
gets fired
i don't go in for that uh
whether they are a friend of mine or a
foe
i don't like anyone getting and no one's
a foe because i don't know who anyone is
they're just these people on the
internet but i don't want anybody to
lose their
job over something that they said
uh in the past that is uh
try they're trying to be funny and
somebody got hold of it and said
you're out of here i don't go in for
that but
unknowingly i probably help someone lose
their job by amplifying this by
retweeting
something ellery smith who i don't know
who's a comedian
apparently uh who i don't know but i
mean
uh she is a comedy writer she writes on
robot
chicken have you watched robot chicken
very funny show you like robot chicken
well phenomenal
well ellery wrote on a robot chicken and
then she tweeted this she tweeted
remember when someone had their snl
offer revoked after and this is by the
way
this is in response to the shooting in
atlanta
uh which is an asian hate crime with no
evidence there's
zero evidence to uh back evidence may
emerge
but at this moment there's no evidence
that this guy went in intentionally
targeting asian people he also killed
two white people
and this is david dobrik but she
in response to this asian hate crime
which we're going to go into a little
bit and then snl that bow and yang on
there on snl
and everybody's nobody knows what's
going on um
it's even the audience at snl like they
expect it to be bad but even they're
shocked they're like
can it be a little better than this uh
and then you see these like stock
puppets these weird accounts on twitter
they're like snl it's the best week yet
i'm like who is
tweeting that who are these people so
ellery tweets after this massacre which
is tragic
insanely tragic she tweets remember when
somebody had their snl offer revoked
after using an anti-asian slur and so
many people thought it was an
overreaction like this guy
i thought it was hateful language begets
violence hateful jokes beget violence
they minimize and they dehumanize and
they allow for the normalization of
terror
so that's what shane gillis was doing
when he was
uh satirizing a uh developer in new york
saying the c words we all know the slur
live in chinatown which is what
his bit was doing and the bit could have
been funnier it could have been more
developed it was on a podcast
um he used that word
and uh this tweet is basically saying
he's responsible for the incel
walking into the uh atlanta massage
parlor and blowing everybody's head off
because he tried to do a joke on his
podcast years ago uh
about a racist uh satirizing kind of
like a racist
uh developer in chinatown and the blanks
live here and that's where they live
and whatever you know it was the
greatest joke ever no but that's
podcasts are not always for the greatest
you know what i mean
there's only one podcast where it's
really high-end stuff
out there this one
um so she said that
because she was probably sitting there
at robot chicken
and she was saying to herself how can i
climb the ladder a little bit more how
can i
how do i get a little bit more clout and
then of course
there's a lot of people that make
offensive jokes on this planet
yours truly being one of them i'm not
responsible for people being
shot in fact i think
taking away offensive humor could get
more people shot
because now nobody has any way to
release any
tension and they have to sit through snl
and go
and trust me that's a lot worse
but then everybody starts digging up the
old tweets uh from her
homemade pad thai didn't put my cat in
it though
blond asians you weren't fooling anyone
these are people with dreadlocks in my
apartment i don't feel safe
that's my favorite there are people with
dreadlocks in my apartment i don't feel
safe
um apparently when the professor asks
you to bring an essay to next class he
doesn't mean your landscaper
not bit hey not bad
you want a writing job on this show now
of course she says i posted a tasteless
racist tweet when i was 17 she was 19
but whatever
uh it was disgusting and normalized the
exact kind of violence i met
how how does that normalize violent but
whatever i get it i get it
the cop reads that tweet then he shoots
michael brown i know how it is except
michael brown did charge the car but
whenever i get it there are problems
between the african-american community
and the cops i get that
it's not all this woman's fault but i
understand what she's saying it's a lot
of her fault
agreed uh luckily i've been willing able
to grow in the past eight years
so my problem and i tweeted i'm like
when you guys do something it's always a
part of your journey you're always
willing and growing and learning and in
the journey
and the journey it's my journey and i
would spit you know and then what shane
or me or nick or anyone does
we are evil irredeemable pieces of [ __ ]
simply for the fact that we don't
pretend to be
a bad person like she's pretending to be
like she's going i was a racist piece of
[ __ ]
well i wasn't i was making a goof
i was making a joke i i don't know
but that's why they get mad at us
because we don't go and say oh my god i
can't believe it the [ __ ] i made that
joke and then the riots
you know like it's no that's not what
happened
i made a joke that people enjoyed people
of that race enjoyed
people of all kinds of vastly different
socioeconomic backgrounds racial
backgrounds religious backgrounds
enjoyed because they understood that it
is a joke
they understood that it was a joke so i
i i tweeted um
something but i got a lot you know i
have a lot of followers on twitter
so i tweeted i said we don't have to
find everything here but i tweeted i
said the
audience trust me i tweeted i said these
are your uh heroes the simon's guy
uh and uh hillary smith who thinks that
the thai people eat dogs these are
progressive heroes again
this is and and then she came out and
said well i lost my day job
because they you know all the tweets she
goes i lost my day job and
she goes i'm still pro-consequence
culture
this is what you don't understand ellery
you're in a cult
and there's only one way out and it's a
deprogramming
or the way that everyone gets out of a
cult which is
you drink the poison you fly a plane
into a building
you strap a suicide vest on and you walk
into the disco attack
you walk into the nightclub or you get
fired from your job at robot
chicken you it's one of the you're going
out
through the shoot there's no other way
out unless you do a massive uh
deprogramming because everything you
believe is
nonsense and to get fired from your job
and going i'm
still pro-consequence i still
i'm still i will be homeless to make a
point
i will be homeless to make a point thank
god
you don't think that uh in the back of
her head she's like yeah i should have
just piped
down you know the shane got piled on he
got death threats i i know the guy the
guy went through hell his family was
getting through
you don't think that's enough he lost
the job you don't think that's enough we
gotta we gotta revisit it every year
and now she can't write on robot chick
which i haven't watched him you would i
like it probably not
i haven't seen it in a decade wow great
so the anti-asian hate crime which
both shane and ellery are responsible
for
to be quite honest with you 50 50.
uh bo and yang who's i don't know him
gay comedian another gay comedian always
nice to me
met him once uh sweet
ish person not a not someone i
actively dislike not some and i'll be
very honest
not a huge fan of the work but i'm sure
he's not a huge fan of my work that's
okay
that's fine isn't it fine is that still
okay to be not a fan
of the work now some of it i am a fan of
like they had this show called i don't
think so honey
where they had a show where were
alternative comics lots of them gay
uh did a minute of material because
because alternative comics happen to be
rich
white a lot of times gay and are not
fans of the work
so they got up and they did like a
minute rant which was funny and it was a
fun show that him and matt rogers did
and they
and then they would get off the stage
and that would be it and then they would
complain that they only had three pilots
or whatever
that year um but no because there's a
lot of just gay people like to party why
would why would any sober
sane human being be a stand-up comedian
why would a gay guy
who's his entire life dealt with [ __ ]
for being gay when he comes out of the
clouds he goes i want to make money and
[ __ ] party
not i want to go to shitholes across
america
and [ __ ] entertain people i just got
back from kansas city
and we'll go into that and thank you for
coming out but what what saying gate no
they go i want to go to [ __ ] miami
and do coke and get [ __ ]
and are they wrong are they wrong
um so if there's a rare breed of us that
make a career of it and bowen's one of
them
and respect for that i don't again
i don't know much of what's going on
there um
well he does the anti-asian hate crime
thing on snl and everybody on twitter is
like this is the biggest thing
there's no evidence again that this was
an anti-asian hacker
but i understand that and i understand
that it's a tragedy no matter what it
affects the asian community so 100
i'm not minimizing that at all the guy
who did it's a scumbag
give him the chair like you know
but this bit are we allowed to play this
i think so yeah yeah i think
small like this is fine yeah i mean if
we could play this
it's again i i don't as
as with most things i'm i'm confused
about
the premise the punchline i'm confused
about it all
so asians are being discriminated
against at harvard and yell
where they're not letting them in and
i i would think there'd be jokes about
that here but there
aren't they're conspicuously left out
but let's watch this little clip but
again i have nothing bad to say i like
colin jost a lot and bo and i don't
really know i just know that i'm not of
i'm not a huge fan of the takes but i
wouldn't be
but i but again i wouldn't be a fan of
the takes right
that's not a shock to anyone him
that's not a shock to anyone on that
show if they say you know tim dillon's
not a fan of the takes they'd go yeah
that's the point we write [ __ ] that we
know
a guy like tim dillon would hate you
a guy that thinks we don't want that
because that's nazi [ __ ] thinking
we like people to get whipped up into an
emotional frenzy for an hour and a half
on saturday night
and go yes
they don't want somebody logically going
why is this this and that that
but let's play this held to condemn the
rise of anti-asian hate crimes
this is the introduction to the bit here
to condemn the rise of
anti-asian hate crimes that's the
opening
should i just start getting brought on
stage as the ghost of matthew shepard
like here to
here to walk in the shoes of many gay
men who died of aids before their time
it's tim dillon
with observations about his mother and
pizza hut
the piles of gay corpses were stacked up
and tim dillon gets to stand on all of
them and deliver a comedy set for you
this
like what an interesting way to bring a
comedian on a comedy show
here to condemn by the way you want me
to laugh
and i'm not saying to do this here to
talk about the benefits
of the rash of asian hate crimes
please welcome because there aren't and
i'm sure there's you know calling it the
china virus didn't help it did come from
china but again
you know trump was not about healing
um but again so to me i go
you want to make me laugh you know but
let's watch more of it maybe i'm wrong
on how you can help is asian cast member
boeing
all right is that um is that my official
title
asian cast member that's how you told me
to introduce you yeah i
set your ass up feels good hi everyone
so no one
again no one's laughing and everyone in
the audience is terrified
so this is how you know a comedy show is
going well
everyone in the audience is terrified of
laughing or not laughing
they don't know whether to laugh or not
laugh picture a king
a tyrannical king sitting on a throne
and his subjects there being like
are we laughing are we not like nobody
knows what to do
this is the show at this point everybody
is on the edge of a cliff not knowing
what's going to happen next uh because
the guy's brought out is to condemn the
asian hate crime so you go like this
you're like
oh is this a bit then he comes out and
he does a little catty fun joke like
am i asian cats member and they go ha ha
oh
what's about to happen now like is what
is about to happen now no one knows
so again this is great things for asians
in this country have been
bleak for the past two weeks and all the
weeks before that since
forever okay let's stop that things
for asians in this country have been
bleak
for the last two weeks and before that
forever
to what country
what country are asians being treated
was it uh cultural revolution in uh
china was it mao
is it north korea what
country out there are asians
much happier than they are in the united
states of america i'm just
again educate i'm sure there's a few
right i'm sure there's a few but
to say that things have been bleak for
asian americans
forever all of this truly it's like
black people can't have a day in this
kind they can't have a day in this
country
you notice that they really can't have a
like they cannot have a day
in this guy it's everybody else just
jumps on like hey
it's been bleak for ages forever among
the highest
uh incomes highest college graduation
rates
very high employment rates
thriving large communities like
chinatown in new york and san francisco
a huge uh great contributor
to culture to the to the economic power
of major cities
what again i'm confused
i get the last two weeks going it's been
bleak for the last two weeks and he goes
and
every day before that since forever and
i know yeah oh but what about the trains
what about the discrimination they faced
uh when they were putting in the train
you know black people
how about that that would be my argument
would be uh
black people again but let's go on here
and i found some posts online with
action items everyone can take to help
oh right so now this is when this is
when he starts to do the bit and you
realize
it should just be a serious talk like
this
is why you can't do ball just do the
talk
just tell everyone their scum and do the
talk i'm more interested in watching
that than the bit watch out off the
rails this goes
the places to donate to yes and here are
some that i found super helpful
six ways you can check in on your aapi
friends and tell them they're so hot
so that's asian american pacific
islander um i guess people just want to
help us any way they can
yeah here's a list of something i've
seen a lot of activists post to amplify
these
asian voices who want more panera's in
north brooklyn
no one understands by the way by the way
to say that this is bombing
is like no one understands what any of
this is
we were just told he was coming on to
denounce the
asian hate crimes and then he said it's
been horrible for asians
for forever in the country and now we're
doing bits about panera
so again the audience doesn't know what
to do they are terrified of laughing
they have no idea what's going on
communities are concerned about yeah it
is for
the ones in my neighborhood but okay
fine here's something we can all do
call your senators and demand that they
know about the lesbian characters
in sailor moon
no offense is this actually helpful to
all asians
maybe i don't know colin okay maybe
what can i say to help how insanely bad
things are
if someone's personality is pungent
asian grandma
it's not a dialogue i have an asian
grandma
you want a puncher there ain't no common
ground mama
yeah that's tough i mean i see my
friends donating and i tell them that's
great but then
i also tell them do more like okay
you're ordering from chinese restaurants
great
do more let me know when you feed your
white kids
chicken feet okay you cried during
menari congrats i
was sobbing into my boner for steven
youne
do more and like why are you telling me
that you
tipped your manicurist well let me know
when you get on your knees and scrub her
feet while she looks at your phone do
more you're right yeah so again again
it's it's it's it
it's riding that fine line if it's not
funny but it's also not
meaningful in any way like i'd really
much rather a
true like crying like hard felt like
you don't know i much give me that
give me that whatever this middle ground
it's like so strange i watched this five
times trying to understand what happened
i don't understand i'm like wait a
minute what's going on
he's like when's the last time you fed
the kid chicken feed
is that what we're doing to
decrease asian discrimination
to to feed people chicken feet i
went to noodle town in new york and
there's a chicken foot in my soup and i
naught on it
i don't care
i i'm i'm confused is eating
eclectic food will that get me off the
hook will no one call me a racist
anymore if i eat eclectic food well
guess what
take me down to chinatown and put on a
bib
you're like i'm confused as to the and
then he goes well you should wash your
manicure's feet i'm like
what does this have to do with the guy
who shot
the the workers
because he was a [ __ ] insult freak
weirdo demon
i don't understand i'm again i'm
confused i know that asians face
discrimination i'm not a [ __ ]
and i know that it's there's been an
uptick since trump but it's this idea
that it's just rash
it's a rash of asian hate crimes are
happening all the time and it's bleak
and horrible it's like
is it good to tell people that they're
living in a country that hates them
which we don't
i don't believe we've seen no evidence
of that is it good to make people
paranoid and depressed and anxious
that they're going to be the victim of a
hate crime when it's statistically
completely
uh incredibly unlikely that they'll be a
victim of any type of hate crime in
their life
let alone a racially motivated hate
crime if they're an asian is it a good
idea
to terrify people and make them more
anxious
and more depressed with all the other
problems they have is it good to lay
on these things you could to layer this
stuff i don't know
i don't feel like that's healthy would i
tell a young gay kid
oh you're gonna have trouble in this
country i wouldn't do that i wouldn't do
that
i would say be smart be kind be
thoughtful
be strong get over the fact that people
aren't gonna like you other people gonna
say bad things about you
but i wouldn't try to paint this
idea that it's like you're living in the
worst bleak
time and you'll never be able to uh
transcend any of this i don't i don't
get it and you're not conscious
sweet guy and he's just sitting there
like hey man
i [ __ ] scarlett johansson i got a lot of
money what do you want me to do
you know what i mean that's kind of the
face by the way they this is the face
he's making
they originally had scarlett johansson
playing bow and yang delivering the
speech
and they had to step in and say let's
give it to bowen
let's just finish this we're almost over
okay you should specifically
look i can't address any of this without
bringing up
class or gender or imperialism i don't
even
want to be doing this huh
can't you you can't address this without
bringing up
imperialism and gender there's there's
got to be a way to do that
in a three-minute comedy sketch there's
got to be a way to do it without
bringing up imperialism and gender
i i i have to believe there is keep
going this update piece
i wanted to do my character gay passover
bunny
but i'm too smart for the show it's too
smart it was 20 minutes long this is
what happens when you let like it like
like college theater majors uh
into entertainment uh or high school
theater kids into entertainment people
who are
emotionally um unprepared for the rigors
of a business that is highly competitive
and what then happens is uh because they
are smart ambitious people many of them
have to figure out other ways to
get ahead and a lot of that is leaning
on identity and going well wait a minute
if you don't give me this opportunity
you are a
you are an ist a racist
a sexist a homophobe and and i like
he's not a bad dude from what i can tell
but he's not
ready to be on this show truly um
and that's really glaringly obvious to
everyone who's seen him in any sketch
and it's crazy they didn't have an asian
before him that is insane
and i don't know why that is i that is
crazy to me that they didn't have a
black woman like that ellen cleghorn
it's like
the diversity blind spots are weird on
this show but it's all ivy league guys
that look like colin jones right
but i mean and i'm not saying that the
guy doesn't have talent
i guess he is ready to be on the version
of the show that they put out now
but this idea that like snl is supposed
to be the great
sketch comics in america or the the next
generation of
comedy all-star i i i am am i
crazy to think that this is not it
that this is truly not it we're eddie
murphy and now we're here
and i'm not and again it's not a
knock on anyone it just feels like
when you sit down and go i can't do this
without bringing up imperial i mean
that [ __ ] that's like a college like
what are you talking about
you're there to kill and be funny and
get your points across about those
things
through humor write a [ __ ] joke
about imperialism don't say i have to
should be speaking about imperialism
then do it make it funny and do it
it can be done like it's just like a
very weird to just give a laundry list
of things you should be talking about
but you didn't because you chose to make
a joke about sailor moon
you chose to make a joke about being a
gay passover bunny
i'd want to hear about imperialism write
about that
let's just finish this up this is not an
attack on anyone again i'm just confused
look i'm just a comedian i don't have
the answers but i'm not just
looking for them online i'm looking
around me
the gofundme for sea agency the
grandmother who fought back against her
attacker raised
nine hundred thousand dollars which she
immediately
gave back to the community that's where
we are as asians
now come meet us there wait a minute
that's where we enter in that's where we
are
that's what one amazing woman did
that's a crazy that's where we are it's
very interesting i love people that just
the collective is everything they're
about
i would never in my life say that i
would never in my life claim to be as
brave as like a gay guy who was like
getting beaten at stonewall
i'd be like that's where we are getting
beat in the stonewall because we're
[ __ ] and no one will accept us that's
where we are as gays i was like no i'm
by a pool in florida
complaining about chicken wings what are
you talking about they're people like
you older you you don't get to be always
a revolutionary
i don't know what to tell i mean that's
an amazing woman god bless her and like
i mean you know god bless her family and
everything but
it's just strange let's kill this we
don't need to finish this um
again i was just i'm genuinely confused
about it
i'm sure someone will educate me who's
smarter than me
i get it you know i mean
i'm not trying to you know make make
myself out to
i was made fun of as a kid for being gay
because i was in plays
i was in theater i was effeminate i was
more feminine than i am
now and although i am more of a [ __ ] now
than i was then
which is interesting as i've gotten more
masculine i've become more of a
a [ __ ] which is interesting many men
have feminine qualities by the way that
are
like destroying society but and it has
nothing to do with sexuality
most straight men i know are useless
they cry
they barely work they are they live off
women
i mean a lot of them are just you know
lost in a haze of porn
also can i ask this question which i
asked on twitter and i believe this
is there a happy medium is there a space
for people that are like hey man
the neighbors are gay how cool is that
neighbors are gay
no problem with gay people but i would
prefer if my children
did not twerk on satan
is there a way to create a space
where we can respect gay people without
exposing my children to a man twerking
on uh
an image of satan is there a happy
medium for those people
because i get it i get it that the
christians go wild with this stuff and
it's a
great distraction but to all my friends
out there that are constantly defending
anything and again this is all like i've
never heard the song i imagine the song
is not great
so what you have to do of course is
twerk on satan now you have a satan's
shoe with pentagrams
but it is a lot
like you know the idea of a kid coming
home and going oh i have satan shoes
with pentagrams on them it's
a lot so the idea that that's not a lot
by the way
how about maga shoes
how about uh donald trump how about like
a maga shoe would
wou would people be allowed to get upset
at that um they're
you have the pentagram it's like and
there's human blood in them as well oh
it's lovely
one drop a drop of human blood
phenomenal
um here's my question to people that
never see
they don't understand why anyone would
have a problem i'm not saying you have
to have a problem with this
i'm saying the people that don't
understand why anyone would have a
problem
what would have been too much
if little nazax had given satan a rim
job
if he'd eat satan's [ __ ] on the video
would that have been too much if satan
had blown a load
all over little nazak's like satan takes
out his big dick and little knox
is sure is that is there any
would anything be too much here
because it it does seem like we're being
a bit obtuse
the progressives are a little obtuse
here and they go yeah we don't
understand why it would be a problem
that a singer whose fan base
a lot of them are children is twerking
with satan and then selling satanic
shoes
we don't understand why that would
bother anyone in a deeply christian
country
it's like it's almost like there's
somebody that goes hey
every argument that was made against gay
marriage let's do them now
let's actually enact them remember how
people said that
that genders wouldn't matter and they'd
be they'd be
you know it'd be like let's let 12 year
olds do whatever they want and
you know let's [ __ ] satan on mtv like
that's all
was gonna happen it almost feels like
somebody's like let's
do that
i don't care what little nasa does
because little 9x
got famous because of a joke right the
song
old town which is fine the whole thing's
a troll to me none of it's real
we don't l it's an nft it none of it it
is what it is right
by the way our nft should be selling the
target is 80 million dollars and it is
not what do we got two grand
let me check on it you people have no
respect this is
our way out of this business it's not a
joke it's real
this nft was our way out him and his
wife this was their wedding present
i gotta sign in one second him and his
wife i was gonna buy them a house with
this money and you [ __ ] didn't do
it we thought joe rogan was gonna buy it
for like five hundred thousand dollars
but that guy doesn't have any [ __ ]
money
i think we have three bids on it it's at
1800. oh oh
someone just went up on it so what do we
got now on it uh
to ethereum so we've got 3 300 yeah
you guys better i thought we're getting
80 grand
don't you want to own this
do you not want to own this how are him
and his wife going to have a wedding
and buy a house that they can live in me
and him are looking at houses now and he
tells me i don't need space
and then i should live with a house
him and his wife have the house i should
live in that house
he told me that i don't need space we're
driving around and he goes yeah you
don't need that much space
we know you don't need a lot of space
because i don't have uh because i don't
have a family like
because him and his wife have been
together for 90 he just has no respect
for anyone who's not like a long-term
committed relationship
uh with someone else who escaped a cult
and the reality is
uh yeah i do like a little space i have
friends i have people i like
uh opulent and grand surroundings and he
goes you don't need any space
and then he gets mad at me because i
i've suggested i had the temerity to
suggest
that my house be bigger than his
that's all how many square foot is your
home
uh 2200 and i said i wanted the yard to
be bigger
and i said and then i played my identity
card i said i don't know if the
neighbors like gay people
so like if i'm hanging out with a dude i
don't want to be like
you know sandwiched in between people
that are like hey
um you know or if i say the word [ __ ] or
we're doing a patreon and i say the word
con
i don't think children should have to
hear that language so i want to be
you know i want to have a little space
and live like a person that's done well
and he he's got a [ __ ] problem with
it and tell me like i should be living
in a place like him and his wife that's
not true
but he they're very cookie-cutter people
they have dogs they're
they're like cookie-cutter people so
like they get into these little
cookie-cutter developments
like a dan carney or anybody like that
you should all live in those places
i should have a long winding road with
trees on either end
and so that people know that when they
get to me they're gonna meet a genius
that's what it should be i shouldn't
have to make small
talk with the neighbors but you
hate that and i know you and your wife
sit around and go he lives in that big
house
all by himself he doesn't need that
space
he should live in a small community like
we do no you've said it
you've said you don't need the space i
don't need the space
i want it i like space
i'm sorry about that i apologize i
apologize
i'm just saying you came at me a little
bit no
we need the space with the yard a
hundred percent but we don't need nine
bedrooms
we don't need nine bedrooms we don't
need nine we don't need nine how many do
we have nine in this house
seven we don't need seven we don't need
seven
how many do you have three well i'll
move in there
tell your wife go big tim you're right
he doesn't need the space he'll be here
tomorrow he's moving in
i mean these two are out of their mind
you think i'm going to live with them
in like some little community
no no no i'm trying to live
and it's not even about money it's about
it's about
grandeur do you understand
it's about grandeur it's not about money
i the cookie cutters suburban i've left
the suburbs to live in cities my entire
life
so if i'm out in texas i want to be in
the woods i want to be somewhere cool
that feels different i don't want to be
in a cookie cutter suburban
thing that's all i mean that's my my
only thing is that i know that like
it's it's lovely and i'm happy for both
of you
but i want to be in in in a more of an
interesting and mysterious
part of the world and you don't respect
that
because you wish that i would like live
on your block
you know and like like some crazy if you
sell stuff online you're definitely in
the right business more people shop
more people are shopping online more
than ever
that means a lot of orders are coming in
a lot of orders you need to ship out
fast that's why online sellers like you
need ship station no matter how much you
sell shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship all of your orders from
all of your sales channels
faster cheaper and more efficiently
import orders from any sales channel
ship with any carrier
access discounted shipping rates
automate just about any shipping task
you'll spend a lot less time on shipping
and a lot more on growing your business
motivate your audience oh
no matter what you're selling amazon
etsy your own website shipstation
funnels all your orders into one simple
interface you can manage from anywhere
even your cell phone
you'll even get access to amazing
discounts with major carriers including
ups fedex and usps
easily compare carriers and choose the
best solution every time
just use my offer code tim dillon to get
a 60-day free trial you need to do this
guys
you get two months if you're starting a
business or you're you're trying to
make a business more profitable two free
months of shipping is amazing
two months free of no hassle stress free
shipping go to shipstation.com click on
the microphone at the top of the page
type in tim dillon that is ship
station.com enter the code tim dillon
make ship happen better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals better help help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available in many hours in
many areas the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log in your
account anytime and send a message to
your counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today
betterhlp.com betterhelp.com
slash tim d join the over the 1 million
people 1 million of them jesus
join the 1 million people who've taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many have been using better
help that they're recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and tim dillon show listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d the echo park homeless encampment
has been uh
broken up and uh if you didn't know
anything about echo park it's a very
kind of a hipster friendly enclave uh
of los angeles and the homeless
uh park was a one of the articles here
is from
december 23rd 2020 it says the homeless
republic
uh of echo park it's la's fastest
growing tent city
what it was was around this park in echo
park that had a lake
they had maybe 40 tents that swelled
during the pandemic i think to about 100
tents
um it was its own economy now the you
know the liberal white women from echo
park were bringing
cookies and yogurt and bottles of water
and it was like
a lot of the homeless people were
younger and they were like kicking
soccer balls around and some of them had
cars and they were on bikes and it
didn't seem that it was people that were
completely incapable of working i'm i
listen i know that providing no mental
health care
no health care uh and the economy sucks
i'm aware of all of that
shutting down i'm not saying that
there's not a reason that people are
homeless
i'm shocked people more of them aren't
than i know i'm shocked um
but this particular one was a little hip
it was a little cool
some of the people that lived there were
um
they had like acted there was one guy if
you scroll down there was one guy who
did a commercial for uh
uh a lady gaga's
yeah this guy here he uh he did a
fragrance commercial
for lot lady gaga's fame oh wow
yeah he was in that but then he's you
know he had a mental thing and now he's
in uh the echo park
homeless encampment and of course a lot
of this dovetails very nicely with all
the protesting because people
come to protest and the dsa comes in and
they charge everyone's phone
it's a good it's and a lot of people
think this is the re like this
is working so a lot of people like this
a great idea it's a thriving
community how dare you try to get rid of
it
from what i understand all the homeless
people were offered housing
um but they didn't want that it was like
hey this is a fun community we all enjoy
it
now there's people overdosing on
fentanyl in the tents
somebody got shot i mean we know how
these things go we know what ends up
happening
we're adults so we know that like yes
rich people are [ __ ] up they don't
care about any of this [ __ ]
uh they they push the economy over a
cliff people
end up being homeless but also these
enclaves of homeless people
that pop up with these underground
economies with drugs and
whatever else is going on there they
tend to go bad as well
because there tend to be some power
struggles and some problems
as well like chaz and uh where was it
seattle
yeah that didn't work so these things
tend not to
work but children and that's the vast
majority of people that are
um you know support this stuff their
their children
and they like the idea of it because
it's like well it's it's
it's like uh the idea of never having to
go to school
every day and we build a fort in the
living room and we'll just have fun and
we can ride bikes all day and i i have
some candy and you have some candy and
we can share it
but this isn't it it's really not it
it's not the answer
okay uh something should happen
that is more productive than this
how great would it be i just thought of
hillary smith just again because i
always want to give people advice for
their career
if she went completely the other way and
just walked out on stage
whenever they do skank fest and she came
out with swastika pasties
on her tits and just started and just
started like whipping a black guy with a
with a with a with a
with a [ __ ] whip and just started
doing like slave point like
there's such another way she can go that
just
i thought about that but here keep going
down here
uh one of my favorite parts of the
article there was a guy
yelling at i forget who it was a cop or
something and they found out that this
guy this guy that was young at the cops
showed up in a bmw x5 and his dad was a
producer for grey's anatomy oh okay
i thought it was this thank you so much
no but so this is it ready so this is
what i'm gonna
no i'm good we're gonna read that
because this is kind of hilarious
because what this is by the way
is you know and again i'm not yelling we
know the lapd
are one of the most corrupt police
forces in the history of the country
right
nobody's defending the lapd but this
idea
that this is a good solution this
tent city in echo park where people are
oding on fentanyl in the tent
um and you also
it was a girl who like had she was she
had like a lot of uh
acceptances to colleges and she got up
and got into the whole protest scene and
then went to this park
and ended up i think odin and everything
and you just feel
if you get up every day to go to work
and you own a house and again you're the
enemy to these people if you do that
but if you own a house you get up every
day to go to work and you look at this
park
and you go you know everybody there's
having fun
they're kicking soccer balls they're
[ __ ] uh
people uh that have passed out on
fentanyl
uh you start saying yourself why am i
the idiot going to work i should be in
the park
having fun so i get that too
but so here we have somebody who wrote
this and this was shared by a comedian
on
twitter who i like i think it's funny
but um
so this is someone's idea and by the way
this wasn't like the worst homeless
thing
ever by the way they were like this they
were like somewhat well-behaved it was
like pretty
but again it was like it doesn't work
it doesn't work for a myriad of reasons
right one of them being that
putting a lot of people in the park that
have mental illnesses
and addictions and and criminal it
doesn't work
why because i'm a sane person and i know
it doesn't work
this was written this was my favorite a
year has gone by
in which housed and unhoused neighbors
have worked together to create a
beautiful
and much lauded homeless run outdoor
community and echo park lake
so again we've been there beautiful's a
stretch
it's not horrible it's not horrible not
horrible but the idea the
uh beautiful and much lauded okay
who's lauding it but whatever we have
built and share kitchens
hot showers a community garden trash
cleanup
a sense of and a sense of security
safety stability and healing for drug
addiction and mental illness
this is my favorite with our own
pioneering forms of therapy
in the absence of any help from the city
government
our own therapy okay
this community has drawn widespread
neighborhood and los angeles
organizational support including
all the things la the dsa blah blah blah
we have also received media coverage
from npr the times
so mitchell farrell this guy who is a
corrupt irish guy
in conjunction with the lapd declared
their plan to forcibly displace
up to up to 50 plus tent dwellers of
echo park lake
asap um
i i think the obviously the problem here
is very
big there's tent cities springing up all
over the country
the covet has been the nail in the
coffin for a lot of economies that were
struggling anyway
biden's trying to figure out how to do
something about that it's gonna be a
massive stimulus
how how meaningful that will be
is up to you know we'll see there's
going to be other things that are going
to have to be done as well in
conjunction with that
um but
this idea that you have a homeless
community um that had grown
very sizable and
it had become a problem there were
violence there were problems this was
not
just you know it was not like you know
people make it sound like it's you know
like uh
you know willy wonka's chocolate factory
when everybody's like working together
it's
not necessarily the case i'm not saying
it was the worst
place in the world but i'm saying you
had the problems in that community that
would you would imagine
springing up in any situation okay and
you could
list we could list them i'm not going to
listen but they're there and there's
overdoses there's
fights there's drugs people get you know
there's old scriptures homeless guys
stabbing each other it's
what happens when you have
a lawless enclave of people that have
mental illnesses
that's what happens um and then the cops
you know went in there and there's
protesters and everything like that
um but the l.a comedians that are really
defending it
should have to live there like the la
comics that really are like this is
how dare they should have to live
in that community because that's not
that can't be the solution
just the same way the solution can't be
putting spikes under bridges
so they can't sleep there the solution
can't be
uh uh a community in a in a park
where everybody's in a tent on making
lanyard necklaces and doing
fentanyl i know it sounds fun
i get it put on the fentanyl patch and
make a beaded necklace
i went to recreation as a child too but
something must go on there must be a
little bit more forward momentum
than a bunch of homeless people kicking
soccer balls
complaining that they didn't get the
part to be an extra in
the you know season three of shrill
there should be something else
we got to figure something else out and
it doesn't help that [ __ ] mitchell
farrell
sounds like the most [ __ ] corrupt
mick
[ __ ] ever
but this is what i mean like it's like
like in the article the guy goes we're
not
like your average homeless
he's like we're not like old he's like
we're not
i think he was kind of saying like we're
not like homeless we're just
we're not your average homeless like
we're like we're here to have fun
we're here to get noticed i mean they
had a brand
the the the echo park lake i mean they
were
very close to branding they were they
were almost there they were
they were a few months away from a
reality show
at the echo park uh homeless run outdoor
community at echo park lake
they were a few months away from a
reality show uh
the cameras going in there and just
filming people
you know fighting each other over a
smoothie they found
but this is the a lot of consternation
on twitter there's a lot of rage people
are very angry about
that these people would just place i
think they were all offered housing i
hope they were offered housing that was
supposedly what happened
you know but
again this is one of those things where
if you point out
that this isn't a solution
it's a problem people look at you like
you are
pro the big business corporate and i'm
not at all i think those people are scum
and the people that squeeze every dollar
out of society and then leave people and
this is why
you warn against things like that so you
do not have large numbers of
economically displaced people mentally
ill people
i'm aware of all that but then you have
the other group of people that go this
is also this is the solution the
solution is
to take over a park and to have people
there
um sharing a hot shower
and you know
a community garden and thinking that
that
is the solution to the problem which is
clearly not as evidenced by
the violence sporadic though it may be
i'm sure it
you know people's people's experiences
there
are different you know but i just i love
the idea of that where people are like
to just even question that that's the
solution
they go maybe that's not a good idea
for everybody to be in the park having
orgies
and doing fentanyl which is how this
girl died
they go so what and
you know so you have people in la that
are like this
is an outrage this is the most beautiful
part of the state these are
people loving each other they were
learning about community
were learning about what it takes to
help each other
maybe but isn't the goal to be in a
house
isn't the goal to be in an apartment
wouldn't the goal be to get some of
those people
if they're doing so well at the lake
let's get let's get them some turlets
and some walls
and watch this baby really cook
if they're doing so well they're making
it sound like they're killing it over
there
and i'm sure that there's merit to that
argument
that things aren't as bad as they could
be because that's what these arguments
all
really boil down to like it could be
much worse and i'm sure it could be
but let's let's get them out of there
let's put them in a situation where they
have the chance to succeed i think
part of the worry of moving them out of
the park
is that that was the only place in
america
that they were safe from the rash of
anti-asian hate crimes
happening every minute every square foot
on every block in the country so they
had created this bulwark against that
by doing fentanyl in a tent uh by the
echo park lake
and uh sharing burritos or whatever
and again these aren't like
old homeless these aren't the homeless
with the bigfoot where they have one
bigfoot
diabetes yeah um this isn't those
homeless
this isn't like these they're kind of
like hey
it's like la homeless like hey i'm an
echo park you know i'm just
like oh [ __ ] yeah and i don't know who
got to live there and why like
it's very interesting to know who like
who got in and who didn't
there had to be some selection process
because there's a lot of homeless people
in l.a
how many of them were allowed into the
echo park we had to have a tent
number one one lady was like we have two
tents which is against the rules but
they thought it was cool so they let us
do it i'm like okay so the co-op board
was like
we can let it we'll let it slide you
know i'm sure there was no
nothing exchanged there and i'm all for
that by the way i'm all for people
flopping around
in a tent on fentanyl the problem is
if you're walking in the park with your
child and they
see that they might i guess be more
likely to
than do fentanyl in a tent which isn't
the goal
can we say that that's not the goal
would it be okay to say that that isn't
the goal that if i had a child i would
not want them living in a tent in echo
park doing fentanyl
is that okay to say or is that
a problem is that a function of my
privilege that i would rather
my child or my friend's child or my
godson
not be doing synthetic heroin uh in a
coleman camping tent
by the lake in echo park is that
something that i'm still allowed to say
as an american citizen i have
weird beliefs i want my late night
comedy show's funny
and i would like uh the people to not
be doing dope in a tent
by the park because there's better
ways to go about life probably
i'm not a perfect person
by you know clearly so this is the
the end they go like this you go to sum
it up to mitchell
farrell to mitch farrell god could you
have a worse name
our demand is simply this please
continue to leave us alone or stand with
us
ignore us as if we didn't exist much
like you've been doing and enjoy your
corruption and greed
or come out and stand with us stand in
solidarity with all of your constituents
not those not just those with money in
housing and watch as we make sure
district 13 becomes a beacon of light
for the world
reshaping and reimagining what it means
to be a community of people living
together
so what they're saying is more homeless
that's kind of the attitude a bigger
camp
let's reshape and reimagine what it
means to live together
like you have a house and i'm gonna live
in a tent
on your lawn and i'll use the bathroom
where i want
and i'll use the drugs i want and i'll
you know if i have a mental illness from
a pedophile i'll deal with your kids in
whichever way that i
see fit uh because we're going to quote
reshape and reimagine what it means to
be a community of people
living together and if again
it is all fun and games if you were not
the father of the daughter who died of a
fentanyl overdose in the park
um who uh you know clearly was led
astray
she went to l.a to protest and get
involved in
in movements which she believed in and
you know i i get it
good for you but it apparently didn't it
didn't go to where it should have went
and she got caught up in this this scene
in this world and she ended up dead
again if you're caught in the crossfire
like that guy the guy who was the lady
gaga
a bullet grazed his leg because he was
caught in a thing that he didn't even
have anything to do with
so again if you're one of these people
that are affected when it goes
bad you don't think this is the solution
and the solution also isn't to ignore
this and to just uh
let uh you know jeff bezos make the
people in amazon pee in bags or whatever
he's doing
you know he's making him to use pee bags
and he's letting them you know i mean
it's crazy
but again i just
it's sad because hillary smith is now
living here
and she's still pro-consequence culture
she's like take they're taking her out
of the park she's like i'm still
pro-consequence culture even though i've
been thrown out of my new home which
i've only been in 24 hours
at the lovely echo park lake homeless
community
yeah hey i don't know what to tell you
man i love box of awesome
it's amazing if you go to bespoke post
their new lineup of essential box of
awesome collection for guys guaranteed
to upgrade your life
whether you're out teaming the
wilderness or taking your home bar to
the next level bespoke post only sends
guys the best stuff every month
no matter what you're into box of
awesome as you cover from style and
crewman goods
to bar wear cooking tool cooking tools
and outdoor gear
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life to get started take
the quiz at box of awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time
each box costs only 45 bucks what's
great about
um this thing is it's fun you don't know
what's coming but you know it's going to
be good you can use it
um you it's tailor-fitted to the things
you're interested in they send you
really cool stuff
and if you like getting stuff if you
like gadgets and gizmos and new things
and you hate shopping like going out and
finding these things but
you you allow somebody that you trust to
kind of curate your experience
these are really good and they're really
cool i get them and a few people i know
got them they're pretty damn cool
each box costs only forty five dollars
but has seventy dollars worth of gear
inside
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com and enter the code tim
dillon at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code tim
dillon for 20 off your first box
expressvpn you need a vpn the
government's trying to get you
everybody's trying to get you you can
access netflix and all kinds of
different countries
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your internet
data to keep you safe from hackers and
eave droppers on your network
if you're any type of anything you got
to get expressvpn it does all this
without slowing your connection
that's why it's rated number one vpn
service by cnet and wired
what i like most about expressvpn is how
easy it is to use download the app on
your phone or computer
tap one button and you're protected
think about how much of your life is on
the internet sadly every site you visit
video you watch or message you send gets
tracked and data mined
but when you run expressvpn on your
device the software hides your ip
address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you
expressvpn makes your activity harder to
trace and sell to advertisers call to
action so stop handing over your
personal data
to the big tech monopoly that minds your
activity and sells your information
protect yourself
with the vpn i trust to keep me safe
online expressvpn.com
tim dillon that's expressvpn.com tim
dillon to get three extra months free
expressvpn.com tim dillon to learn a lot
more it's so important right now that
you protect yourself
from the big business and the big
government and
give money to expressvpn and the only
big uh person you should be supporting
is me
big tim a lot of fun stuff uh
coming up that we're very excited about
did i send you anything else to talk
about it
oh well this this was a great oh yes yes
yes i almost forgot
this is a new segment on the show do you
remember where are they now
remember that where they would find
stars
from your favorite sitcoms and uh
musicians
maybe one hit wonders or people you
hadn't heard from in a while
where are they now well we're doing it
again
this is the tim dillon show where are
they now this is from the new york times
they were guantanamos first detainees
here's where they are now i hope one of
them's a music manager and working with
demi lovato let's see
let's go to where they are now
oh man just two of the men are still at
guantanamo all right that's depressing
let's get rid of that i want to know
where are they now
who's improved
what do they tell us not really one guy
don't tell us one guy they accidentally
released and he's like the leader of the
taliban now
why wouldn't he be here's where they are
now they're plotting against our country
for
good reason here's where they are now
they're
uh they're doing all the things we
thought they were doing before
that they probably weren't even doing
do they do they not give us an update on
anybody is there not one success story
is there not one person we tortured
mercilessly for a decade
based on dubious intelligence that came
out and now runs a weed startup
is there none of that going on is there
not one bitcoin entrepreneur
nobody's big in crypto there's not one
of these guys who launched an energy
drink
when he was laying there being tortured
going i wish i had more energy
but they won't let me eat my food and
they keep waking me up every few hours
um you know which bush assured us was
necessary
and man i'd love to have an energy drink
right now so he came up with an energy
drink
is he having problem getting the first
round of funding
is the seed capital the issue
ben saul a law school professor in
sydney australia who in 2016 helped mr
hicks a guy named
david hicks you see the australian
uh convert to islam yeah they went to
australia he said he's working in
landscape gardening and had ongoing
physical and mental health issues as a
result of his treatment
by the us before and at kim i mean hey
man
when george washington said we should
not torture the british
we what a [ __ ] you know what i mean
what a [ __ ] i think it's a great idea
that we uh
started a labyrinth of underground
torture prisons
where we just rounded up people that may
or may not have been a terrorist
whatever that means and tortured them
mercilessly many of them like teenagers
in their late teens
and tortured them mercilessly for years
uh president bush
instead of being painting should be in
jail right now he should literally be
injured
if it was a functioning democracy which
it's we know it's not
he would be in prison he would be in
jail for this dick cheney would be in
jail
donald rumsfeld would be in jail but of
course it's you know
it's not and the barbecue in kansas city
sucks
so what's the point it sucks
because it's like tgi fridays it's that
sweet whiskey glaze sauce
i don't want to start i don't want to
start [ __ ] on a specific restaurant
i'm not trying to hurt anybody making a
living
i'm just saying this austin's the king
of barbecue
i hoped in that article they were going
to tell us that a few of the people at
guantanamo bay
who we waterboarded uh were now running
a taco truck in
austin
i mean it's amazing remember that when
that came out everyone's like it's a
conspiracy it's a conspiracy theory
these people talk less about
discrimination than like almost anyone
by the way
people that you know where they should
be on snl
they should be on saturday night live
doing sketches doing bets because this
was one of the most disgraceful periods
of our country's history and we were all
sold it by 24 in jack power because he
was a ticking
time bomb well what happens when there's
a ticking
time bomb i don't know like a memo
saying that bin laden was going to
strike and that they were going to use
planes and then
you had all the intelligence you had it
at the kuala lumpur meeting
with khalid sheikh mohammed and you and
norad and the jets ended up being
somewhere else in addition to that you
mean to one of those ticking time bombs
one of those oh i don't know
hmm tick tick tick
um but that's a great news segment for
the show where are they now and i think
this is just the beginning i think uh
the guantanamo mates are just the
beginning i hope
i hope that america can really embrace a
lot of the good that we've done
where are they now where are the kids
whose soccer games in pakistan we bombed
where are they now tell us where they
are now
where are they now how about the people
in yemen we've starved to death
because we keep it giving saudi arabia
money where are they now
but we don't like to talk about this on
snl because it's uh depressing
all right you want me to write some
jokes about uh imperialism
put me in coach i'll write you a bit or
two
you want me to go in there i'll tell ya
i'll tell you what's
uh happening but um
yeah i mean where are they now
i didn't realize there's like 800 people
that have gone through guantanamo and
they're out now yeah
yeah well guantanamo is just this great
idea
um you know where we would bring people
that aren't guilty of anything
a lot of them literally many of them and
then torture them
uh giving both the by the way there was
some documentary where like a guantanamo
guard
could i think he converted to islam and
became friends with like one of the
dudes
oh really there's some documentary about
that that's how you know
what you're doing as a country is
working that's how you know you're doing
it's good when your guards are starting
to convert to islam because they feel so
bad
about torturing these people that's how
you know it's a great move it's a good
move
and then bush is painting up people in
hijabs talk about how much he loves
immigrants
i ever talked about how bad trump was
because he you know tweeted something
mean at megyn kelly
that that makes a lot of sense is this
them where are they now
are they now are they protesting the
closure of the echo park homeless
encampment
after initial after an initial period of
confinement
they now live with their families in
housing provided by the qataris they can
move freely around the cosmopolitan
capital
the woman shop at local markets the
children study in a pakistani run school
but need
the blessing of their host country as
well as the united states and
destination to travel abroad
so they're on like house arrest kinda
the trump administration transferred
only one detainee and admitted al-qaeda
terrorists who was sent to his native
saudi arabia to complete
a military commission prison sentence
under a plea agreement negotiated during
the
obama administration among the 30 yemeni
prisoners taken in by the oil state of
oman
were blank blank blank he found work at
a factory married and is now father to
two children
i met how many people we just tortured
to death there
you know
like god only knows and by the way
guantanamo is the one we knew about
there was all these black sites we
didn't know about where people were just
getting tortured to death
yeah you know
well there you go folks that's the
government we all know and love
look at that isn't that nice i get it we
need a military we can't have terrorists
running around but also like
you know this doesn't seem to be the
most effective way to do it
to bring in a bunch of people torture
them and send them back into their
countries of origin
to then come back and attack us now with
a reason
you know what i mean it's like let's
give him a reason
you know yeah you yeah 911
now we're going to give you a reason
we'll give you a real reason to do
another one yeah
oh listen to this abbed al malik a
yemeni was sent to resettle in a
peaceful nation montenegro he received a
government stipend for a time after his
release in 2016 but that ran out
he tried to raise funds by selling
artwork he made it guantanamo
nft
but made his last sale last year and
as ambition to work as a driver in god
they're never materialized as the
tourism-dependent
economy tanked that's sad
he wanted to be a guy like a tour guide
montenegro
it's sad like imagine him like he's a
tour guide in montenegro he's like it's
beautiful here
he's like and i should know the places
i've been
i mean he's just doing you know
four of those first 20 men all released
by the bush administration could not be
found
they're dead or we killed them or
they're doing things that
will lead to problems perhaps but
all right that's depressing enough i
just like to catch up on them where are
they now
i wanted more success stories and i'm
sure that there are more success stories
i think we're just probably looking at
the negative side of the picture i'm
sure there's a lot of people
that rebounded from that in a big way
and are
using what they learned to build a brand
and i hope they're all building brands
that's the question
we should have gary vaynerchuk talk to
people that would torture to gitmo and
teach them how to build brands
what a great clubhouse room garyvee
tells you how to build a brand when you
wake up every two hours
screaming
we have hoodies coming they're on their
way we'll get them very soon
if you like them buy them if you don't
we are on the road um
we are late with this episode we're not
going to be late anymore florida's sold
out a lot of this is sold out
anything that's left is on the website
most of it's sold out chicago's still
not on the website right
guess not okay great i don't know why
but that's fine
um like subscribe to the youtube channel
to the uh all the [ __ ]
that we do follow me on social media
team jbl instagram twitter
uh i post updates there follow
uh ben avery up ben avery is good
give dan carney a follow if you want
we'll be
out uh doing stand-up we'll be doing
stuff
and um we'll be um
[Music]
focusing on getting a guantanamo guy
on the show to kind of update us on
everything he's been up to
what's it been like
you know probably the australian guy
right david david hicks
well who no i want a real like i don't
want some convert i want like a legit
guy
but i also want them to i want to ex
i want a media landscape where
a 25 year old white girl explains to a
person
who is brutally tortured by our
government why he has to have his
pronouns
uh in his bio on social like why
why he needs to identify as a man or a
woman
that that to me is the moment when
everything clicks
when like when ellery smith or any any
white chick turns around to a guy and
goes i
i understand that you've been through
things
but what i want you to do right now is
really
understand how your words are weapons
they're daggers so i want you to just
respect me and refer to me as they
okay and you're sitting there is like oh
okay
god you know i i hope
i want to see that there's just
something i want to say
i want to see somebody that was on
guantanamo bay going to snl
and do a funny bit and have conjurers
sit there staring at them like
like what like what the hell happened
here
you know the guy's like and then they
put they put the
electrodes on their penis and colin just
kind of sitting there smiling like
he's like really that's
ah that's tough what do you say to bone
because that's
tough huh so i want one of those guys
i want one of those guys to go and then
they put water down in my throat and
showed me pictures of my family
and they told me they were already dead
and colin goes
that's tough that's tough
that's tough and you know and then he
turns around and he goes
but i don't want to be talking about
this i wanted to be doing the bit
about but people want more paneras
in brooklyn